[Music]
tonight judge brett kavanaugh is
fighting back and standing up for his
good name and his
reputation and he's demanding a fair
process he says he won't be intimidated
after days of negotiations with the
senate judiciary committee
professor christine ford has now agreed
to testify
about the allegations she made against
judge kavanagh
let me be perfectly clear these are
serious allegations i've said it many
times
professor ford deserves to be heard and
those
allegations and accusations should be
taken seriously
and this coming thursday you the
american people will be able to hear
from both
professor ford and judge kavanaugh in an
open setting
now chairman grassley of the senate
judiciary committee he was right to hold
this hearing
and the republicans have been and are
being extremely
fair and accommodating and they're
taking these allegations seriously
but tonight we need to step back and we
need to remember what we're talking
about here
these are 35 year old sexual misconduct
allegations made by
professor ford two congressional
democrats
now the claims date back to when ford
and kavanaugh were in high school
senator dianne feinstein she was aware
of professor ford's allegations since
july she sat on them she kept them a
secret
until after kavanaugh's public hearing
and after lengthy meetings
with judge kavanaugh in fact dianne
feinstein refused to give
senate republicans our colleagues the
full unredacted letter where the
accusations were first made back in july
until today now professor ford cannot
remember a date or location of the
alleged incident
the four witnesses that ford herself
listed
to corroborate her claims they are all
now on record denying what
ford is alleging and just a short time
ago judge kavanaugh sat down with our
own
martha mccallum and categorically
refuted
these claims once again let's take a
look
i may have met her we did not travel in
the same social circles she was not a
friend not someone i
knew you don't remember ever being at
parties with her ever i do not
and this is an allegation about a party
in the summer of 1982 at a house near
connecticut avenue and east west highway
with five people present i was never at
any
such party the other people who are
alleged to be present
have said they do not remember any such
party
a woman who was present another woman
who was present
who is dr ford's lifelong friend
has said she doesn't know me and never
remembers being
at a party with me at any time in her
life
all right tonight kavanaugh is now
facing one more allegation because over
the weekend the new yorker
well they brought up another decades old
claim against kavanaugh
in this case a woman named deborah
ramirez she's claiming that in the 1980s
again when he was a freshman in college
that kavanaugh exposed himself
at to her at a drunken college party at
yale university
ramirez herself wasn't totally sure if
kavanaugh was the perpetrator
according to the new yorker she became
quote quickly
inebriated at the party her words she
told the new yorker that she was quote
foggy and slurring her words and she
even acknowledged that she had
significant memory gaps from that
evening
now the new york times well they spent
over a week trying to corroborate her
story
talking to dozens of people and the
times said this quote
they have interviewed several dozen
people over the past week in an attempt
to corroborate her story
they could find no one with first-hand
knowledge miss ramirez herself contacted
former yale classmates
asking if they recalled the incident and
told
some of them that she could not be
certain mr kavanaugh
was the one who exposed himself and
those who ramirez listed as witnesses
in yet another case here well to the
indecent
charges well they're all flatly denying
and this is what they said we can say
with confidence
that if the incident debbie alleges ever
occurred we would have seen or heard
about it we did not
the behavior that she describes would be
completely
out of character for brett in addition
some of us knew debbie long after yale
she never described this incident until
brett's supreme court nomination was
pending
the new yorker also interviewed ramirez
best friend at the time of the alleged
incident
and she's also denying any knowledge of
her claims and she said quote
this is a woman i was best friends with
we shared intimate details of our lives
i was never told this story by her or by
anyone else
it never came up i didn't see it i never
heard of it happening
now judge cavanaugh also denied
emphatically
these decades-old charges in a statement
he wrote quote
well these are smears pure and simple
and they debase our public discourse
but they are also a threat to any man or
woman
who wishes to serve our country such
grotesque and
obvious character assassination if
allowed to succeed
will dissuade competent and good people
of all
political persuasions from service as i
told the committee during my hearing
a federal judge must be independent not
swayed by public or political pressure
that is the kind of judge i will always
be i will not be intimidated
into withdrawing from this process the
coordinated effort to destroy
my good name will not drive me out the
vile threats
of violence against my family will not
drive me out
the last minute character associate
assassination will not succeed
and tonight cavanaugh once again denied
these charges
in his interview with martha let's take
a look i never did any such thing
never did any such thing the other
people alleged to be there
don't recall any such thing if such a
thing had happened it would have been
the talk of campus
the women i knew in college and the men
i knew in college says it's
inconceivable
that i could have done such a thing and
the new york times
has reported that just last week
the person making the accusation was
calling other classmates
saying she was not sure that i had done
this again
again just asking for a fair process
where i can be heard and i can defend my
integrity
and during this interview he took it
even a step further let's watch this
people generally in high school i think
all of us have probably done things we
look back
on in high school and regret or cringe a
bit
but that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about an allegation of
sexual assault i've never sexually
assaulted anyone
i did not have sexual intercourse or
anything close to sexual intercourse
in high school or for many years
thereafter
and the girls uh from the schools i went
to
and i uh were saying that all through
all these years that are in question you
were a virgin
that's correct never had sexual
intercourse with anyone in high school
correct and through what years in
college since we're probing into your
personal life here
many years after i'll leave it at that
many years after
then brent kavanagh went on to defend
his character as a young student
at yale watch this was there ever a time
that you drank so much that you couldn't
remember what happened the night before
no that never happened you never said to
anyone
i don't remember anything about last
night no that did not happen
did you ever have any sense that any
kind of the description of the behavior
that i just described with these
you know women being taken into rooms
and and raped or having sex with a
number of men consensual or otherwise
that that was going on at the parties
that you were at i never saw any such
thing
any such thing i certainly never
participate in any such thing but i
never saw or heard of any such
thing and we
we were i was focused on trying to be
number one in my class
uh and being captain of the varsity
basketball team
in doing my service projects going to
church
the the vast majority of time i spent in
high school was studying
or focused on sports and
being a good friend to the boys and the
girls
that i was friends with we have these
great lifelong friendships
now despite all these charges judge
kavanaugh says he will not be quiet he
is vowing
not to be intimidated into withdrawing
his nomination
and while judge kavanaugh is standing
firm rightly demanding a fair
process it is so important to remember
the toll
that it also takes on a family again
where's the presumption of innocence
let's take a look it's very difficult
it's very difficult to have these
conversations with your children
which we've had to have some broader
terms for
our youngest but they know
brett and they know the truth and we
told them at the very beginning of this
process this will be
not fun sometimes you're going to hear
things that
people feel strongly and you need to
know that
and just remember you know your dad
now while president trump he is standing
by his nominee tonight and he predicted
earlier today that in fact he will be
confirmed let's take a look at this
it would be sad indeed if something
happened
to reroute that this is a fine man and
we certainly hope he's going to be
confirmed
and quickly his family has suffered
his family has suffered what's going on
is not something that should happen
brett kavanaugh is an absolute
outstanding person hopefully
he will be confirmed quickly
now this all comes as one false mirror
about judge kavanaugh has officially
been debunked
mainstream media democrats were
gleefully spreading
a rumor that female students were
coached by a law professor
on how to dress in an outgoing way when
they were
interviewing with judge kavanaugh a
rumor that the professor
is completely denying now despite
everything we just showed you
and before any public testimony there
are people in this country this should
not be political
democrats people on the left they have
already convicted
judge kavanaugh and according to them he
has no presumption of innocence
no right to be heard no reason to be
believed
no due process you know actually there
are lawmakers
law makers that are throwing law
out the window and claiming his guilt
by accusation this should not happen in
this country
take a look the senate shouldn't simply
rely on hearing two conflicting accounts
and
decide well we're okay with not knowing
uh we're okay with the fact that we
might be putting
a someone who committed attempted rape
on the supreme court of the united
states
i believe her listen first of all
anybody who comes forward at this point
to to be prepared to testify in the
united states senate
against someone who is being nominated
to one of the most powerful positions in
the united states government
that takes an extraordinary amount of
courage not only do women
like dr ford who bravely comes forward
need to be heard
but they need to be believed they need
to be believed i just want to say to the
men of this country
just shut up and step up do the right
thing
let me just say right at the outset i
believe
dr ford i believe the survivor here
there's every reason to believe her
she has come forward courageously and
bravely
i believe her i stand with her and do
you hope she shows up on monday do you
hope that she talks i don't think she
should be bullied into
this scenario where it's a he said she
said it's a sham hearing
and i i don't think she should
participate in it dad i believe
professor ford i think she's credible
and i think
when the investigation is finished and
when she testifies
and judge kavanaugh testifies i think a
majority of senators
will find her credible and i don't think
i didn't ever thought
kavanaugh should get get appointed no
presumption of innocence now at the very
same time all the people you're watching
here
we have a case not 36 seven or five or
four years ago
where keith ellison the number two
person the number two guy
at the dnc has been accused of repeated
physical
and emotional abuse and the dnc has
smeared and slandered and
ignored the person making that
allegation
that's back in august this year so what
you're watching
is a democratic party playing politics
sadly exploiting a sexual conduct
allegation accusation that's it
for political gain jumping to
conclusions
rushing to judgment now these are
serious allegations
and as i've said we should hear from the
accuser but tonight
every american republican democrat
conservative liberal
this is why you need a healthy dose of
skepticism let me tell you why
the attorney representing professor ford
her name is deborah katz
well has views on sexual assault that
have been extraordinarily political and
inconsistent at best for example she
said this about paula jones nobody in
the media reports it
now paula jones suit is very very very
weak and she alleged one incident that
took place in a hotel room
that by her own testimony lasted 10 to
12 minutes
she suffered no repercussions in the
workplace she then said of jones
accusations quote
clearly a one-time incident that took
place
in 10 to 12 minutes and she was not
forced to have sex
she left of her own volition the courts
increasingly are finding
that is not enough to create a sexually
hostile work environment
claim and she also defended creepy
senator al franken quote
context is relevant he did not do this
as a member of the u.s senate
yeah he did and by the way he did this
in his capacity
of someone who is still functioning as
an entertainer
clearly professor ford's attorney has a
left-wing radical inconsistent
political agenda and the daily caller
even
uncovered back in 2017 the same attorney
said she vowed to resist
president trump we've got the tape here
it is
finally over the finish line the new
attorney general this morning
grateful to the colleagues who fought
for him i can't
express how appreciative i am
for those of you who've stood by me
during this difficult time
it was a bitter feud to the very end
we're going to fight that
we are going to resist we will not be
silenced we're going to fight back we're
gonna resist
and now we're also learning that
professor ford is adding one more person
to his legal team an attorney named
michael bromwich he's the lawyer
currently
representing fired fbi deputy director
andrew mccabe
now this brings us to our hannity
history lesson surrounding the
democratic
playbook now every two to four years
in politics every election cycle
democrats use the politics
of personal destruction to literally
name
the character of their political
opponents even if it means
lying in the process they demonize all
conservatives
not a conservative i know that has not
been through this
in fact every four years every two years
republicans are racist
sexist misogynistic homophobic
xenophobic islamophobic
oh they want dirty air and water and
they want to kill your children
and throw granny over a cliff now the
left has also
rushed to judgment in the wake of other
major events they've been wrong
on this program we've been right we
didn't rush to judgment
in the duke lacrosse case remember when
the media falsely accused richard jewell
the summer olympics bombing remember
because they said oh he fit the profile
of a lone bomber
because he lived with his mother richard
jewell was listening to my radio show i
was a local host in atlanta at the time
he once thanked me for being the only
one not to rush to judgment
remember the rush to judgment in
ferguson in missouri
you remember the rush to judgment in
baltimore and with freddie gray
remember when obama said the cambridge
police acted stupidly
you know we have on this program adopted
the
we will not rush to judgment we will
wait we will see
on the case of the duke lacrosse kids i
went to meet with their parents
in the case of trayvon martin george
zimmerman i met with george zimmerman's
attorney
and george zimmerman asked him tough
questions and you see it now
every time there's a supreme court
nominee well and it
happens to be a president that's
republican that appoints him
we saw it all the time judge bork we saw
clarence thomas
politically remember 2012 mitt romney
was sexist he had binders full of
women's resumes and remember they turned
his
efforts to hire women into an attack
about him
being a sexist mitt romney was not
democrats smeared romney remember they
falsely accused him remember harry reid
of being a tax cheat
and then after they won the election he
had no regrets about sp spreading these
lies these false attacks
this happens this is why americans have
a
duty to be skeptical because the media
the left wing have been wrong
it's in their playbook we see it every
two years every four years
every supreme court nominee and every
big high-profile case that they
politicize
here's a look at uh harry reid let him
prove that he has paid taxes
because he hasn't i don't regret that at
all the koch brothers
no one would help me they were afraid
the koch brothers would go after them
so i did it on my own so no regrets
about mitt romney about the koch
brothers some people have even
called it mccarthyite well
they call it whatever they want um
romney didn't win did he i regret
telling a total lie
and smearing somebody from mitt romney
to
robert bork to clarence thomas to george
bush
frankly every conservative i know that
has been forced at some point in their
life to deal with these
baseless smears attacks character
assassination
now the most often used character
assassination in the democratic playbook
is to call republicans racist it happens
every election
season take a look many republicans
talking coded racial language about
takers and losers
they demonize president obama and
encourage
the ugliest impulses of the paranoid
fringe
if you accept the support of clan
sympathizers
before you are president you will
accept their support after your
president
he's going to let the big banks once
again write their own rules
unchain wall street
they're going to put you all back in
chains it's wrong what the leader of the
republican party and this congress
are doing in blocking an accurate census
because they don't want to count
everyone that they
don't think they can count on they are
in favor
of affirmative action if you can dump
the basketball
or sink a three-point shot but they're
not in favor of it
if you merely have the potential to be a
leader in your community and bring
people together don't tell me we've got
a colorblind society
june 7 1998 in texas my father was
killed
he was beaten chained and then dragged
three miles to his death
all because he was black so when
governor george w bush refused to
support hate crimes legislation
it was like my father was killed all
over again when you don't vote
you let another church explode when you
don't vote
you allow another cross to burn
real smears real character assassin
assassination and it happens predictably
every election season and it happens
with supreme
court nominees this is gutter politics
at its worst and
sadly we're going to see more and more
of these tactics
as we now march what 43 days or so
towards the midterms
we're going we'll have a lot more on
this in a moment but first breaking
today it also appears the deputy
attorney general rod rosenstein
is hanging on to his job at least for
now after the new york times issued a
report
accusing rod rosenstein and they're
sticking by it applauding to secretly
record president trump
and planning to rally cabinet officials
and evoke invoke the 25th amendment
rumors spread that rosenstein might be
out of a job that was going on all
morning this morning
tonight rod rosenstein has been in
communication with the president
and apparently they will be meeting on
thursday